rapidement vous les deux enfants
important d'une info parce que pour le
coup c'est voilà vous êtes vraiment
prendre quelque chose sur louboutin avec
guillaume qui va nous parler notamment
christian louboutin est effectivement le
secret de cette fameuse semelle rouge
qui a tant fait rêver les femmes photos
chics et christian louboutin ces grands
chausseur français année plus cher aussi
c'est un des plus chers français est
alors voilà et il est connu pour sa
semelle rouge
oui vous voyez paraît beaucoup on en
parle aujourd'hui moi bêtement je
pensais que la chemise olalala comment
dire là la semelle rouge
elle venait de louis xiv puisque vous
savez qu'un jour le 14 est allé dîner
aux halles et en marchant en y allant
chercher dans du sang neuf voilà je vous
ai mis là je vous ai mis le portrait
mais non malheureusement
et donc il a marché dans du sang neuf et
il a eu les talons rouges et du coup
toute la haute aristocratie française
depuis le xviie ohlala nous allons
devoir d'état là c'était une manière de
dissocier du peuple oui ça les fait rire
dès qu'on parle un peu de trucs
intelligents de l'émission vers le haut
et c'est bien c'était ça la différence
est une manière de dissocier c'est comme
le petit prince d'angleterre ont des
shorts jusqu'à 8 ans ça y est faire
comme les gars du peuple voyez on est en
bas des petits chalets et donc apprécié
pour parce que magali à des louboutin
est donc en fait il vient d'avouer que
si elle il a des chaussures haut avec
des talons rouges c'est parce qu'un jour
en faisant ces prototypes il a il a vu
ça mec ça il avait une tache et il a
demandé à sa son assistante de mettre
son vernis à ongles sur la semelle rouge
et il a fait en sorte que cette
chaussure est la plus connue au monde
maintenant que c'est une marque et que
les américains ont essayé de le copier
et que non alors il faut quand même
saluer l'art français
ah bon
les sondes en un va tout nous avons sa
série et 2 millions de personnes qui
travaillent et 150 milliards on en a
besoin donc on ne se moque pas de merci
plus tôt rata tu te perds gratuit grâce
à ça non j'ai voulu faire un petit point
info c'est intéressant comme le johnny
pourquoi effectivement pareil le le
fameux sac de nabila pourquoi il avait
cette valeur là enfin on apprend des
choses passées louis xiv ici quoi c'est
bah oui bah c'est important les hommes
et 14 il avait rien à voir